joining me now is Missouri Senator and
member of the Senate Judiciary Committee
Josh Hawley senator
this sets USANA precipice uh for I think
a very very dangerous period in our
society and our electoral processes
at this point the Fulton D.A has
indicated that they will seek higher
bonds against any of these defendants
who are convicted and of course
processing would include mug shots what
does that tell you here
well what this tells me is that this is
the latest effort to keep the ruling
party in power Laura that's what this is
about this is indictment like what
number 200 I mean who knows there may be
more indictments to come and what's
clear about this is this is an effort by
the ruling party the Democrat Party
across States and the federal government
to make sure that anybody who criticizes
them gets indicted and it's not just
Trump although they're focused on Trump
it's also Catholics who have had their
parishes infiltrated it's also pro-life
demonstrators who had SWAT teams sent to
their doors it's also those who have
protested peacefully that the FBI show
up and knock up their doors it's parents
who've gone to school board meetings and
now been labeled domestic terrorists by
the Biden Administration I never thought
we'd see any of this in American history
we've seen all of it in just the last
couple of years and the Common Thread is
if you challenge them if you challenge
the ruling party the ruling Elites they
will use the force of law against you
and yeah this is crossing a Rubicon
Laura we've got to beat this back we've
got to defeat this attempt to rig an
election in real time because that's
what they're trying to do they're trying
to make sure there's only one outcome to
the election in 2024 and it's the
Democrat winning
well I don't think they'd have much of a
problem with a different type of
Republican like a Mitt Romney Style
Republican right because he he maybe
wouldn't rattle the cage like someone
like a trump or DeSantis maybe even
Glenn young can would down the road or
Vivek ramaswamy someone like that but
this is a message to anyone who would
even think of working for a conservative
Administration going forward don't you
agree like if if you can get indicted as
a lawyer giving an untested legal Theory
to a president or urging an action which
you know hasn't been taken before
post-election but is a theory that a
number of people agree with some don't
then all bets are off why would you go
into government service
absolutely this is a message they're
trying to send a message loud and clear
and the message is don't mess with us
and why they're going after Trump
because he messed with them he
challenged them across the board he
challenged their pro-war policies he's
challenged them on Ukraine he's
challenged their globalist agenda that's
ripped off our working class for years
hollowed out the industrial base of this
country and made our workers in this
country slaves compared to China and
these other nations that have taken away
our jobs taken away our technology Trump
challenged all of that and the message
is if you challenge them on this stuff
if you challenge them on these policies
they hold dear they will come after you
if they if you challenge them on their
pro-abortion religion they will come
after you so I think the message is real
clear don't challenge us don't go to
work for anybody who will challenge us
don't vote for Donald Trump or anybody
like him or we'll treat you as a
domestic terrorist and I tell you what
Laura this is a recipe for one party
rule in this country and if that's the
case this isn't the United States of
America anymore our constitutional
democracy doesn't this anymore
Senator thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else